[Music]
now has the national trust forgotten its
founding mission
an organization the biggest in the world
of its kind set up to preserve british
history artifacts and
architecture seems to be ashamed of its
properties
all in a bid to join the culture wars
charles moore former editor of the
spectator and columnist for the
telegraph
writes this week's cover article broken
trust and joins us on spectator tv now
charles welcome to the show it's been an
understandably difficult year for
organizations like the national trust
because of covet
but you're writing about a different
phenomenon yes
and of course covert made it worse
because they decided to do what they did
at the same time as dealing with
horrendous and uh
inevitable problems about covid um
so they sort of entered the culture wall
last summer when they
produced their um report or so-called
interim report on
slave slavery and what they call
colonialism in its connection with
national trust properties and so they
opened
a tremendous um storm of argument
and it wasn't a good report it was very
politically motivated
it wasn't terribly accurate and it made
a false
um conflation between slavery and
empires if they were absolutely
empires automatically as bad as slavery
is and so on and of course this was very
disturbing to
members who were already disturbed by
the wider circumstances
and confusing and it was clear that the
motivations
of this report were not the normal sort
of scholarly motivations which should
motivate
a heritage charity but were highly
political and
explicitly so actually um and so you had
this feeling
very very difficult feeling for a great
heritage organization that the people in
charge of it actually don't like
their properties um and that's very
demoralizing
and uh it makes people feel that the
whole purpose of the
trust which has sustained it for more
than 100 years is being um
undermined what's incredible is that you
mentioned in your piece that
on the panel of people who put together
this report there were no academic
historians and indeed
some of the leading academia surrounding
this very complicated and nuanced
history
weren't cited at all so i mean who did
who did do the report in the end
well the report was mostly written by
national chess
curators and i think that was a
deliberate decision by the trust to show
that their people were endorsing it
and those curators are often very good
at their particular subjects but there's
no special reason why the expert on
textiles
should be able to talk about the
politics of imperial history
um or furniture or whatever it may be um
and the
guiding influence behind the report is
who
is professor coryn fowler of the
university of leicester
who's not a historian um she's a
professor of post-colonial literature
not on the staff of the trust but
retained by the trust
to help with these matters and she has a
very very clear very hard-line agenda
which she expresses in her book with the
revealing title of green unpleasant land
in wishing to show that the patrimony of
britain and particularly england
is a slave
slavery polluted empire polluted
patrimony and therefore sort of wishes
to cast a shadow
over the many beautiful places and
buildings
and the whole history really which the
national trust
cherishes i think it's entirely
appropriate that
a body like the national trust should
understand these things and not try to
hide anything
but i think it's quite inappropriate
that it should give a platform to people
who
are actually against the very things it
tries to protect
conserve and celebrate and it even does
this
in its educational program so professor
fowler um
has this program which the trust is a
national trust program
called the colonial countryside project
in which they take school children 10
year olds
round houses that they see are linked
with slavery
or what they call colonialism and invite
the children to have a look at it and to
write creative writing which of course
because the children sort of know what's
expected of them is in
very very hostile um to the places and
sometimes to the
um occupants the former occupants of the
places who often actually gave their
properties to the trust
so you have a poem saying what a
dreadful man lord kerzen was he was one
of the greatest benefactors of the trust
ever
and of conservation in general both in
india and in britain
and so you have this feeling of
hostility right within the system
to what the national trust stands for
and it's not necessarily
um therefore because it's motivated by
that hostility it's not necessarily
learned it's not necessarily well
informed or accurate
lots of things they said were about
winston churchill for example and
chartwell were wrong factually wrong
and this also is very undermining
it's simply not correct and
of course the millions and millions of
members the membership now declining
we'll worry about that rightly so so if
you were a historian with a different
perspective you mentioned this campaign
group restore trust
were you consulted because it is a very
nuanced
view on a very complicated and long
history and
i can imagine a lot of these questions
are quite hard to answer you know how do
you say if an economy is
quote unquote based on slavery or
colonialism
when you know everything gets muddled
together quite a bit
did they consult a wide range of
opinions
no i wouldn't i wouldn't say they did
because everybody in the colonial
countryside project
and pretty much everybody in the interim
report
are of only one view um and they
as far as i can see made no effort to
get
wider views i think the way to approach
this subject is
to think more about the whole historical
context of the acquisition of all sorts
of property
by the national trust and why it
mattered what it tells you where it
comes from and so on
and then you will find um that um
there are all sorts and some of them are
just as controversial as slavery believe
it or not i mean the classic one which
could easily be addressed by the
national trust is the dissolution of the
monasteries
in which um by killing and theft really
state theft
um monastic institutions were destroyed
the
the monks were sometimes hanged and
their property was grabbed by rich
friends
who then became richer of henry viii um
now that could be presented as a
tremendous stain on some of the
trust properties such as a phantom's
abbey for example um
but i think a sensible historical
approach to that would not be conceal
concealed
it should be told but not to try to work
up a sort of lazar of indignation
about the whole thing the story of
country houses the story of the
countryside is
often to do with power and money and
sometimes it's to do with robbery and
violence
and that's important to understand
but give it the full context don't
single out
um a couple of things that happen to
obsess you
and also don't link one of them slavery
and
empire as almost identical concepts
they're jolly well not and a great many
people who serve the empire
did very great things in the world i
can't think of anything great about
slavery but i can think of
many great things in the world done by
the british empire and by
imperial servants and one of those great
things by the way was the abolition
of slavery so let's have some nuance
let's have some context let's have some
depth and breadth
and let's also remember that the trust
is about objects and places
it needs to give them their wider
historical context but it is not
a political body it's not about the
history of parliament the history of war
the history of
of um industry all this things
come into it it is about the these
objects these places
um these beautiful landscapes these
beautiful houses and works of art
and that's what it's good at and that's
what it should
maintain with love do you think that
there is more that the national trust
could do when it comes to diversity i
mean the plight of catholic monks
in the middle ages is probably not as
fashionable these days as
multiculturalism and people from various
communities i'm always amused when i go
to the national trust that
my family are the only non-white people
visiting do you so do you think there is
more that the trust could do to
quote unquote use that awful phrase
modernize
well i think that um first of all i
don't think it's surprising because on
the whole
ethnic minority populations still live
more in towns
and are less likely to be close to a
great many
national trust properties but i think
there's something perverse going on here
if you start to preach that these houses
are based on iniquity
why would that persuade um
ethnic minorities who are supposed to be
the butt of this iniquity
to come yes very true if you you know if
you
um if you're proud of your heritage
though also honest about it
that's what attracts people of of any
race you know i don't have a problem if
i go to
um if i'm an ethnic minority in india or
whatever when i visit
i want to see the great um
examples of indian culture and i don't
have to keep thinking to myself
am i quote uncomfortable that's one of
the words these people love
uncomfortable
here no um i am i'm interested
and but of course i'm not going to be
interested if i'm always um
told how evil it is yes absolutely and
finding chelsea because i know we have
to let you go very very soon
there's now a national trust
chairmanship empty would you so would
you fancy throwing your hat in the ring
no no i mean um uh i think there will
now be a long process
um actually there should be a long
process where they need to think very
carefully
and they need to find someone who um uh
really can recognize how badly things
have gone wrong
and put them right but not i hope in a
terribly confrontational way it's got to
be firm
but it's also got to be healing because
the great tremendous
historical advantage of the national
trust is in its name it's national and
it's trusted
and that trust has been greatly
diminished
in some cases positively broken and
the next people have to really work hard
to restore it
[Music]
you